are we good to go sonia
yes chairman no
thank you thank you members welcome to
rochefort district council's remote
review committee meeting this evening
and welcome to anybody watching this via
live stream
we'll start with agenda item number one
which is apologies for absence
i don't believe there are any so can you
just confirm that
no apologies received chairman thank you
agenda item number two substitute
members i don't believe there are any
that's right agenda item number three
non-members attending um sonia can you
just
clarify the non-members attended this
evening's meeting
yes uh chairman i believe we have um
uh councillors fd
wooden williams belton
rowe and smith visiting
thank you very much welcome to all of
you
um agenda item number four which is the
minutes of the meeting held on the 5th
of january 2021.
can i just ask a question please you can
yes
uh thank you mr i'm sorry i can't see
anything
so you'll have to forgive me um i'm
having to use a phone because there's a
council equipment's failed
just a query we have um quite a few
portfolio holders attending which is
normally unusual review committee is
meant to be relatively independent of
the portfolio holders other than when
they're presenting
can i just ask what the protocols are
for this if they're allowed to
participate
because it's they're not allowed to be
on the committee
so i just wondered if you could clarify
that
thank you councilman i do believe if i
recall that i think this was mentioned
at the last
review committee meeting um and i
believe um
angela did confirm that portfolio
holders
um are entitled to attend the meetings
um sonja is that correct i think i'll
recall that being the case
yes and yes it's a participation i'm
queried
the um the the the answer to that is
that
um as as as the chairman's confirmed um
portfolio holders may attend meetings
with the review committee
and um if you know if if they're invited
to speak by the chairman they may do so
otherwise they they attend in observing
uh capacity
thank you for that clarity thank you
sonya
okay agenda item number five to receive
declarations of interest
including any whipping declarations
if any members that have if you can
raise your hand using the raised hand
icon
okay there doesn't appear to be any
yes i mean the only thing i would say
chairman is that it may it may be wise
to just um
uh just clarify with uh with any members
like cancer mrs mason who are attending
via telephone who obviously
you know can't can't raise their hands
in that way
okay yeah that's a good point thank you
sonya um if there are any members that
aren't able to use the raised hand icon
if you can just let us know if you need
to
um network
it's fair equipment
okay i'm still thinking that nobody
needs to um
sorry council mrs mason yeah
put yourself on mute just for a moment
unless you are
declaring an interest are you well i
can't i'm on a phone
okay i don't have that
thank you very much
okay um item number six which is the
capital and treasury management strategy
for 2021
22. um and this item members this is for
uh to consider the report of the
assistant director of resources which
sets out the council's capital and
treasury management strategy for the 21
22 period and seeks the views of the
review committee
on the approach proposed in the strategy
before it's presented
for approval at full council on the 16th
of february 2021
um the report should have been
circulated to all members who hope
have had the opportunity to to review
that and have a look at it
um this evening i believe i'm going to
hand over to
naomi lucas just to introduce the report
to members um
and know me i know you've done this a
few times for us um if you can just
talk us through the report highlight any
um important aspects of the report that
you would like to
to raise to members and then answer any
questions that members may have
um councillor simon smith the portfolio
holder is also attending this evening's
meeting
um i did email you over some questions
earlier knowing me and you have
responded i thank you for
um for coming back so quickly on those
um and if i can hand over to you knowing
me just to
to introduce the report for us yes thank
you chair
um as you've um set out
um yeah the report that's presented to
members tonight is the council's annual
capital and treasury management strategy
for the next financial year 2021-22
um and the purpose is um to seek the
views of the review committee tonight
before it's presented um for formal
approval to full council on the 16th of
february
members will be aware that um the
council
is obliged to comply with the prudential
code for capital finance for local
authorities and this
plays a key role um in how we
manage our capital finance um it also
requires
the section 151 officer which is myself
to comment specifically on the strategy
adopted by the council
the potential code says that the capital
strategy should set out the long-term
context for any capital expenditure
and investment decisions and should give
due consideration for both the risk and
reward
and the impact on achievement of
priority outcomes
and the strategy sets out the overview
for the governance process for approval
and monitoring of capital expenditure
and includes a projection of the
council's capital financing requirements
and sets out how the council would make
um provision for
the repayment of any debt although it
should be noted that the council does
not
currently have any debts
the strategy also sets out the council's
approach to its treasury management
activities are set out at section 8
and includes the criteria for how funds
will be invested to
ensure that the council's monies are
safeguarded from loss and that we
maintain sufficient liquidity to ensure
that funds are available when needed
i just draw members attention to section
three of the report which is on page 6.3
um which just provides um a brief
overview of the
different sections within the report i'm
alright i'm aware it is a lengthy
report with quite a lot of um detail in
there so that gives a kind of overview
of
of what is included within the strategy
and you can see that it includes um
sections on as i've mentioned capital
expenditure
and capital financing treasury
management investments
and the council's approach to any
commercial investments
and how we maintain them knowledge and
skills
for capital and treasury management
activities
um so all i would really say is that the
strategy is pretty much
unchanged from previous years there's
been no
significant change in our approach
either to our capital investment program
or to our treasury
management strategy um the
proposed plans for capital expenditure
are detailed within the report
um and yeah i think that's probably
all i was going to say but i'm obviously
um happy to try and answer any questions
that
members may have thank you
thank you no me um council hooker you do
put your hand up first but um
councillor simon smith has indicated to
speak i think i'm going to go to
councillor smith first
um council smith okay with you
thank you chairman um i would just like
to take the opportunity to
compliment naomi on on this piece of
work um
you you see a similar sort of report
each year
but it's not to underestimate the the
thoroughness with which
all of the aspects of the report have
been gone through
as naomi mentioned the um prudential
code
uh we we have to comply with and we
believe that this report allows us to
meet
the required standards and just one
little thing that naomi
said uh with regard to debt that we
haven't got any debt
i just can't stress how immensely proud
we should be as a council
that at this moment in time we haven't
got any debt thank you
thank you thank you councillor smith
council hookway
uh thank you chairman yes i've just got
um
uh one question for naomi um uh
i i have been um reading some
reports um in the press and stuff like
uh that in relation to um uh
looking at interest rates into the
future now obviously we've been dealing
with very low interest rates for a long
period of time now
um but there was some discussion and
talked that uh
there was the possibility of interest
rates going to zero or negative
um now um i i don't know if um
if the council has got any um plans in
place for
um any um money in uh accounts or
whatever
uh that might might be potentially
um under threat if um if we were in a
situation where there was uh zero
interest or negative interest
on account um i think it's highly
unlikely but
uh there is there is that there was was
some
some serious discussion about that
possibility in the future
um is there any other plans for
alternative uh ways of investment to try
and reap some
better returns thank you
uh thanks thank you councillor um
so just to reiterate that um in terms of
managing the cash of the council the
priority is always and firstly security
of the balances that we invest
um then liquidity so our ability to draw
down on those cash balances when we need
them and thirdly
yield so once we've met the first
criteria of
having secure and and liquid investments
um we then obviously look to optimize
our yield within our our strategy um
uh authorizations and as as councillors
will be aware as a council we have
a fairly low risk appetite and we we
haven't got any kind of risky
investment mechanisms at the moment so
um our balances are predominantly
in um uh yes bank accounts and
um low risk money market funds
and council hookway is right in saying
that obviously interest rates have
dropped significantly over the course of
the year
and in fact we're not projecting any um
investment returns on our investments
for the next year because
um interest rates are are very near to
zero now
um however we have got sufficient um
yeah different funds open to us at the
moment that that's not causing any
particular issue for us in terms of
placing our
our our cash balances but that is
something we're obviously keeping an eye
on um
uh yeah as i say we've got sufficient
places to put our money at the moment
um and i think it's unlikely that um
any of the um institutions we're
depositing
would go to a negative interest rate
position but as i say we're not actually
forecasting it um to receive any
interest income over the next financial
year
thank you naomi um council hook i hope
that answers your question
um if if you're happy with that would
you just mind putting the hand raised
hand icon
down for me and we'll move on to
councillor dre
thank you chairman um i agree that the
report
is very extensive um
and uh adequately uh explains the
uh situation but i've got a question in
respect of um item 5.4
in respect to a 6.6 just a matter of our
clarification
it refers to the adoption of the ifrs
16 in 2021 22 and it's to do with the
identification of
least premises um and i know
that that work is still needs to be
completed
i'm just wondering if we can have some
idea of when that will be and do we have
an estimated number of leases that are
involved please
thank you council addre that was a
question actually
i did put to naomi earlier as well so i
i have had a response but
it was a bit late in the day knowing me
did her best i actually asked the
question quite
late so um know me if you can just um
just retweet your answer for
for councillor draymond for other
members
yeah thank you councillor dre um so ifrs
16 is an accounting standard
which the council was expecting to have
to adopt from um
the next financial year but actually
since this report's been published it
has now been deferred
um for another year so we won't actually
have to um introduce that standard until
now the the following financial year
um however the principle is um yeah of
the council's
leases that it that it has um which were
treated as
operating leases which effectively means
that um
they're part of our revenue budget and
we pay them just year on year and which
are finance leases and essentially have
to be capitalized onto our
balance sheets and that therefore
potentially has an impact
on um yeah our capital expenditure which
is presented in
in this report so um
yeah we already report on our leases
within our financial accounts and i can
um refer members to the relevant
paragraph or sort of section in in the
financial accounts
um which is um 12a
of the 1920 financial account sets out
the least um
properties um and values um
from the council so the underlying um
the underlying leases the council's
whole won't be impacted by this change
in accounting
and treatment all it will mean is that
some
will potentially be shown on our balance
sheet rather than in our
revenue budget so it is essentially an
accounting adjustment
it won't impact on the actual kind of um
financial position of the council
does that answer their question
thank you naomi yes thank you councillor
dre thank you naomi
um councillor mrs shaw thank you chair
naomi can i just confirm in this uh
regarding councillor hookway's statement
um can i confirm in this current climate
it would be very hard to go to any bank
or any other financial service
to be able to get any higher interest
rates because they just
can't do it at the moment
um thank you councillor sure and so
i think you're right in that there's
there's um
all um investment vehicles are
experiencing a decline in returns but
obviously there is a continuum between
risk and reward
and the greater the amount of risk
you're prepared to take the potentially
the greater return you could make
um but i just referred to my previous
point that um
our strategy is a low risk strategy and
therefore
our options to invest in riskier kind of
investment vehicles is is
quite limited and not something we would
choose to do at this point thanks
thank you for the confirmation
thank you
have any other members got any questions
at all
just bear with me one second sorry
no okay thank you um naomi as i've
mentioned
to you earlier thank you once again i
mean nobody's asked any other questions
um it is a very thorough report as it is
or has been certainly for the last few
years
um members there are four
recommendations on this report
can i first ask um many members
wanting a recorded vote if you are would
you please use the raised hand icon
and if you don't have the raise hand
icon if you can just
let just let it be known that you do
wishful for a recorded vote
okay it doesn't appear that any members
are wanting a recorded vote this evening
um so if members are happy
to take the four recommendations in
one go that's okay isn't it sonia
members are in agreement with that
uh yes that's uh that that's that that's
fine uh chairman i think um
i think sort of looking at the uh
looking at the report
um we've got uh
if you if you look at sort of
recommendations um
one one is for noting in any event isn't
it chairman and so is
two um and and three it's only the last
one really
um uh that uh it's a it's a
recommendation to uh to counsel
um i think the third i would recommend
that the first three of
you know if members can note that
and then vote on the on recommendation
for
police chairman thank you sonya
okay members so if we can take the
recommendations one two three
first these recommendations are just to
note
so if you can if you are happy to note
those recommendations
could you use the raise hand icon please
if you don't have the rose hand icon if
you can just let it be known or raise
your hand on camera
or use the microphone
excuse me i haven't got a i can't raise
my hand
hello hello christine
i can't raise my hand because and you
can't see me so you're going to have to
ask me on the phone
raise your hand okay um so counselor mrs
mason
are you yeah no i'm quite happy for it
to be noted that i didn't want to be
excluded
okay thank you thank you councillor mrs
mason
i'm looking down it appears that um
okay
have you recorded a note though sonia
chairman um chairman if it assists
because we're only noting
um you know it's it's easy it's easier i
think if members just uh
indicated they you know they've got any
issues with that and we move on to
recommendation for
okay lovely thank you sonia
recommendation for members is that the
contents of this report
be recommended to full council so i
think
if anybody does not or if anybody
objects to the
sending list to full council can you
please indicate now if you are in
agreement
just do not raise your hand only raise
your hand if you object
so i'm looking at that and nobody's
raised their hand so i'm
receiving that as no objections and
everybody's in agreement
to recommend that to full council
chairman the um you you might just want
to check with the
uh with the with uh with with councillor
mrs mason as she's she's not able to do
that
counselor mrs mason are you able to can
you hear me
if you can if you can unmute
okay there's no response from um
counseling mrs mason at the moment
i'm sure that counselor mrs mason if she
has any objection will come back to us
later on during the meeting to let me
know
okay thank you members um thank you
councillor smith
thank you very much chairman i know
you're leading the team so thank you for
attending
thank you yeah i i was saying i haven't
got any objection mr chairman i don't
know if you can hear me
i can now thank you mrs campbell yeah i
can't
i can unmute but someone keeps muting me
so i'm not sure what's happening
okay thank you counting mrs mason
naomi are you staying for the next item
thank you
i think if it's okay i will leave now as
well thank you
okay thank you for coming this evening
naomi yeah
always saying i haven't got any
objections that if you can hear me
i can now thank you yeah i can't uh
mason because i can hear a conversation
a moment ago thank you
okay moving on to item number seven
which is the emergency planning and
business continuity review
excuse me chair john joe mcpherson's
lost connection
she just said okay thank you thank you
thank you
is that okay councilman folks can hear
us yes thank you very much chairman
thank you a bit of a testing evening
this evening but
we'll get there item number seven
emergency planning and business
continuity review
um this is to consider the report of the
assistant director of assets and
commercial which sets out the emergency
planning information
um which was previously requested by
this committee um for this item this
evening we welcome
and the assistant director matt harwood
white
um and also jeff stacy and the portfolio
holder
um i'm just trying to look at the screen
uh counselor mrs
belton thank you all for attending this
evening
um matt if i can just start with you if
you can just introduce the report to
members in the same way that name has
just
with her report and just highlight any
errors that you'd like to highlight and
then answer any questions that
members may have course no problem at
all chairman um leaving chairman tv
members
i hope you can hear me clearly um
there's scattered and so i'll just
briefly uh
just set the scene for the report if
that's helpful and of course happy to
take any questions afterwards um
but jeff the council was emergency um
playing a business continuity officer um
chairman
this report uh before this evening um
was in response to specific questions
raised by members of the meeting of
review committee um in january of last
year
and scheduled for april of last year um
those meetings were cancelled due to the
council's response to the chronovirus
pandemic
and so the report has been rescheduled
for this evening um
it's um important to point out to know
that this report doesn't address
um other aspects of emergency planning
and business continuity
including the council's response to the
pandemic
as that was subject to previous reports
or previous reports
to this committee the most recent one
being last month
um uh so chairman the report
responds to the specific points raised
at that previous meeting that i
mentioned and just to highlight those
within the report
they were regarding provision of
training for
members for emergency rest center
volunteers
information about the communications
protocol
um information regarding the council's
out of hours number
on the council's website um and
instruction of a testing regime
for that service um chairman i think
that it's a relatively
concise report just given those um just
those points were asked to come back to
the committee on
so hopefully the information in the
report is uh answers that clearly
but of course more than happy to take
any questions should there should
members have any thank you john
thank you very much um no members are
indicating to ask any questions
at the moment um so i'll i'll begin
um i usually like to let members start
but um in this instance i will
um if i can just refer you to paragraph
4.3
on 7.2 um
it says there that in order to relaunch
the communications protocol to members
the following training has been prepared
and submitted to the standards committee
working group for inclusion
can i just ask when that was submitted
to the standards committee and when
we're expecting that to actually be
implemented
thank you chairman um i would refer to
my colleague jeff for the fine detail on
that i believe only recently been
submitted
been submitted to member services um
i believe is that the situation without
i don't have the data yet i believe
um jeff says will correct me if i'm
wrong i believe that has only just
recently been submitted german
i'm happy to feedback except for the
general helps in terms of dates when
that could be held
i believe it's a recent addition i
believe
okay thank you
[Music]
yes it's it's yet to go to uh to that
group
um to uh be put forward to uh to sort of
go into the
the program of uh of member training
[Music]
okay thank you so just so just to
clarify
it it has or it hasn't been submitted to
standards
no it hasn't been submitted to to
standards i i thought it was going to be
by the time the uh
the report went through that that's uh
that's not the case it's yet to
uh it's yet to go through to the
standards committee
so do we have a date of when it will be
put to standards
uh i'm not familiar with uh with the
programme of
of meetings for the stand committee i
don't know if sonia can help me on that
one
chairman if i may i can take that one
away chairman and come back in writing
uh to confirm a date when that will be
submitted and when the training can be
held share if that's helpful
yeah it would be thank you um i know
that a couple of other members have
indicated so
i'll just ask this another quick
question here um just a
very um
how do i put this the emergency planning
i'm sorry
paragraph 11.3 on page 7.4
refers to emergency planning and
business continuity have been the
subject of internal audits
and the recommendations completed um if
i could just start who
who conducts the audits and makes those
recommendations
um when was the last one actually
completed
and really i i would have thought that
that
may have played a part in this report
are you able to anybody come back to me
on that mat or jeff
jeff i can pick that up so 11.3 so that
this refers to
the council's internal audit so carried
out by our own internal audit team
um so um jim cavani and his colleagues
that carry out audits across all council
services so they
produce those reports work with officers
pull together
action plans recommendations and we pick
those up internally
i believe reported to audit committee um
that
paragraph just refers to any actions
that were picked up through that report
have been actioned
um but as i say this that was covered in
detail in earlier iterations of this
report
we haven't gone into that again as it
was covered previously we've just
focused on the
on those sections to come back on but
that's a internal audit function that uh
carried out that uh
jeff had just noted and when was the
last one done
the last one i'd have to check sherman
um it was fitting the normal rolling
program that
uh the audit team set um on their
rolling program but i can check when the
last one was done
and feedback chairman
um yeah if you could please thank you
and my last question which
is not a question i know there are some
um newer members on this committee
who haven't covered this subject and
topic before
um in paragraph 10.2 on 7.4
there's reference made to the recovery
moneys
by the beltwind scheme i just wondered
if one of you just for the
benefit of all the members here this
evening and anybody watching can you
just very briefly
um just tell us a bit about the beltway
scheme just very quickly how it works
i know we have talked about it before
and it was something that members have
always been interested in and asked
questions on so
if you could just give us a very brief
summary i'd appreciate that
i'll do my best chairman that that is a
uh that sections within the resource
implications section
um so the detail of that would be
probably best um
for naomi to answer who's unsupported
how long with us but essentially it just
is a
a scheme that the council is able to
draw down funds to recover costs
um essentially um uh i can certainly
provide more detailed answers from the
area if that's useful outside the
meeting
um but essentially it is just a process
that we can draw down monies
by governments uh initially uh and they
claim that back
um via by that scheme um chairman
now that's fine it was just a bit of
clarity for for members that might
may not be familiar with that with that
scheme
um okay uh councillor mcpherson
thank you chairman um uh thank you
chairman you've already raised on the
points um
i was going to um as chair of the
standards i can confirm this hasn't come
before us
yet at the working group um but just to
reassure members i'm
sure that with sonia's able support we
would be able to form a working group to
review this
as soon as it comes through to us um
just one question please on page 7.4
item 12 around parish councils
um so could i ask do all parish councils
have emergency plans in place
and if so does the officer know if
they're published anywhere
thank you councilman thank you chairman
um
i'll let jeff maybe answer the detail
but uh jeff certainly worked
and offered to work with all parishes in
the past to help them support their
plans
um in terms of where they're published
um i'll have to defer to jeff
jeff you could uh maybe pick up on that
for me
yes it um it's very much the
local arrangements emergency planning
arrangements for each of the parish
councils
is geared to what works for them um
i don't believe many of them actually
publish their plans
most of them are sort of internal type
of plans
one of the key things is knowing who to
get to be able to contact
um and you know having those points of
contacts
so there are issues with publishing that
that sort of detail
um so mostly it's um
yeah the sort of internal parish plans
uh which they share with me so that we
can
we can work together in an emergency
uh chairman mayor come back you
certainly can yet
thank you um it's all really actually
didn't ask my answer my question about
um how many parishes have actually got
these plans
um and if they're not published i think
the officers just explained that really
they should be
so is there anything we can do to
encourage them to
even if it is that initial advice for
residents as a point of contact
jeremy i know colleagues and jeff will
work closely with
um with parishes we'll certainly
encourage them to publish and continue
to work with them
but i think jeff has set out it
certainly is um
uh it's for them to publish those those
reports and
to do that the right way but certainly
we'll support them in drafting them and
advising them
um chairman casper person to uh how best
to do that using jeff's experience
expertise to support them for that
thank you
thank you very much um councillor dre
thank you um chairman um the report
refers to
emergencies and major emergencies
and i think i understand that the
difference in this context
but be interesting to know the number of
out of hours emergency calls we've had
say in the last
12 months and in the event of a major
emergency whose responsibility would it
be to call that as a
major emergency
chairman um jeff can i ask you to
just briefly walk members through uh how
we categorize emergencies there was a
section of a reprieve report where you
set out um
the various standardized um categories
of emergency
be able to hire that for us please jeff
yes i think the key thing really is what
they call a major incident
um that can be declared by
any agency um and it's really defined by
the fact that
it is something beyond their resources
and capacity to deal with
so they're asking for for mutual aid
um you may be aware the most recent case
um
funny the most recent case was the
problem in the response to coronavirus
by the hospitals
and they were becoming overwhelmed so
asked for assistance from other agencies
so it was declared a major incident
um through the essex resilience forum
strategic coordinating group
um and they were given help and in fact
that
help has enabled them there you'll soon
be seeing a a declaration that
we've now moved back from that stage
state of uh
being in a major incident um so it's
a major incident is where an
organization can't
cope with its own resources and is
asking for mutual aid
thank you and thank you
does that answer your question
councillor grey it does yes there was
the other question as
the number of out of hours emergency
calls do we know
oh yeah
um the emergency calls
again we have different sort of levels
of
of calls which are dealt by our out of
hours um
sort of facility um
yeah i'd have to sort of go through the
figures the the there are certain
categories of calls that come through
which if they're dealt with successfully
by the out of hours people we
we don't even sort of log um and then
there are others if they need
action it's the those are the ones that
are logged and passed
pass through um i would have to ask for
figures on that they
they do do a report um which which give
the
the figures of the ones where they've
had to take action
um but as an indication
there's they're usually dealing with a
sort of couple most evenings
thank you mr stacy thank you chairman
thank you councillor drain um councillor
wilkinson
thank you chair i think this is a follow
on actually from councillor dre's
uh question paragraphs five point one or
five point two
talking about the out of house number um
i know that it's
entitled prominence of out of house
numbers on council's website
my question was going to be more around
um
some acknowledgement that perhaps we
shouldn't have to but sometimes you have
to
spell out to to some people how they can
contact the council because a lot of
people don't go onto the website or they
don't know how to use the website
and i wondered if we if we advertise out
of ours
uh contact details elsewhere so maybe
through social media with a like
um forgive me if you're only referring
to the cancer website to know the
paragraphs entitled that but i just
wondered if that was the case
particularly with the the pandemic and
whether there's been an increase with
that
thank you thank you
yes
yeah i can answer that one if you like
um yes the the the question in the
uh report was relating purely to the the
prominence of the number on the
uh the council website um
but uh yes it's um
it is advertising in sort of including
on
uh yeah the door of the the the council
offices and things like that so there
are other ways that it's it's come
through
we also did some work following this
suggestion
um to make it come up in other searches
so not
just being on the council website but if
you if you search through say a google
search or something like that
and then you'll you'll come up with
emergency numbers for the council as
well
um uh
yes i mean it's not really an
opportunity to sort of advertise it on
social media as such unless we were
trying to bring calls in in relation to
a particular incident
in which case that would be done at the
time in relation to that particular
incident
but no it's not done on a routine basis
as far as i'm aware
on social media
okay thank you for that um
councilman uh yeah just following on
from the question about the parishes i
think that possibly
looked to be a possible mood amongst
this committee
towards nailing down an agreed
management publishing plan with the
parishes
not saying well some right ones some
don't but i know who to talk to
because we can get disasters that can
come on us quite bigly
quite largely like environmental
disasters we've got a nuclear power
station north of us we can have
something really big that happens we've
got a pandemic
at the moment and it's a question really
of all right knowing who to talk to but
knowing that inside
the plan of that person you're talking
to there's a possibility of some
sort of support and who who they would
call on what they've got
if it you know it means resources so
just to look at it
with more structure really than just
saying well i can ring somebody because
if you can't get out of them where are
you going to go then you know you need
to
perhaps uh look at a it's not a lot of
work but just a bit of a belt and braces
approach and looking at the standards in
the parishes as well to help them which
you do
when you say you do but just to see a
bit of structure around it that's just
my view
that's it thanks okay thank you council
emil
um councillor stanley
thank you chairman uh just one point
really is uh
on this emergency numbers and what have
you um
well i know we're in a pandemic but we
just had
two floods basically in uh this locality
where i live
um and uh to be perfectly honest
our response wasn't very good um
in as much as to help the resident it
was more of
uh from the fire brigade they'll pump
you out sort of thing
um which is which comes to me like for
sandbags
and and that sort of thing that we i
don't know
if we have uh a location for
uh those inflatable sandbags that
inflate when they're
when there's water hitting them um but i
do know there are some with
the rainy town council but do we have
any locally
for flooding as we already know it it
definitely does flood down this area not
so much anywhere else but
do we have a location for these
emergency
kits if you like or from who do you
contact
kate thank you um council stanley
explained myself very well but
it's it's all to do with the emergency
and and
is there is there do where is it sort of
thing you know
have we do we have we put we told
residents where to go
in the case of that sort of emergency to
pick up these sort of things before
the emergency happens okay
thank you councillor stanley um matt are
you wanting to come back on that
specific point that cancer stand is
raised
if that's helpful please chairman yes it
was just me thank you
just to flag um uh the council has a
as a flood forum as some members be
aware just to um
just to pick up on that so we coordinate
um i mean flooding is a
it's a key issue it's been we've
reported on that before in previous
reports and so the council takes a um
a coordination approach of those lead
authorities so the
leaflet authority essex environment
agency highways and other partners
putting those together you know it
definitely is a multi-agency approach in
terms of flooding and that's why the
flood form was pulled together
um so that response is best coordinated
through that group
of which the the council is a key
partner of course so our our overall
approach that is coordinated from that
group
um so that hopefully that answers that
query
doesn't quite answered my query in
effect that
when when you've got something happening
to you and and it's near dire straits
where
do where do the residents go we've had
i've i personally have had phone calls
uh myself for flooding areas but
i don't know where i would get the
equipment or whatever it is
from ldc okay councillor stanley that
that that's fine can you actually if you
wouldn't mind if you could just try and
make the
your actual query or your question a
little bit more specific so that
somebody either matt or jeff can attempt
to come back and answer it
i i think i'm kind of getting the the
point you're raising but
hello okay well thank you yeah yeah
sorry
uh councilman i have got a note here to
come to you after um
councilman was going due to talk to ask
so i will make a note
you've got a question so um if i can
just come back to you councillor stanley
just to give you the opportunity
[Applause]
yes sorry uh um are you able to specify
your question just a little bit better
for me
what i'm trying to say uh that rtc
have a have a store if you like that
that residents can go to through a
counsellor at rtc
where have we got a store or whatever it
is
where we can contact somebody to get
that
to get that equipment for emergencies
um apart from being told oh well contact
your
local forum but the flood's already
happening sort of things there's no good
contact in the local forum because
it's not good doing that it's already
what i'm saying okay i've got an
emergency
you've got an emergency it's there right
in front of you an emergency
right thank you council stanley um matt
if i think what cancer stan is trying to
get it if a member of the public did
phone and reported
are you able just to very briefly
summarize
what you would look to do or what you
would look to implement and where you
would go
of course yeah i think jeff's probably
best place to answer that one in terms
of our specific response
we do publish that on the website but to
give a brief um
response to that jeff can ask you to
comment please
all right a little trouble there getting
off the mute um
i mean we the the short answer
to be honest is that we are not
resourced
to provide a 24-hour emergency service
um that's what the emergency services
are there for
um so uh no we have no sandbags we
have no staff who could deploy sandbags
um
if if not that sandbags are particularly
helpful anyway that's uh
that's one of these myths that you can
do anything much with with um
sandbags so where we do concentrate on
is through things like the flood forum
where we can look at more at the
the prevention and protection um for
future events
um because we just haven't got either
the resources or the
facilities for an emergency response
okay thanks jeff so essentially what
you're saying is that
if a member of the public did report for
example
a flood as as cancer stanley has as it
detailed we would really be more of a
kind of a central point to coordinate
with emergency services in
dealing with that problem is that
correct
yes the emergency services would lead an
emergency response
we would certainly look to do what we
could um
to assist them so if for example there
was a requirement to
evacuate people because they'd been
flooded then we would help
through the rest center procedures um
to find somewhere for them to to shelter
help them to
find alternative accommodation if they
were unable to return to their homes so
it's that sort of support that we would
we would give um we wouldn't take on the
role of the emergency services
okay thank you jeff um councillor
sparring
thank you chairman uh just to reinsure
councillor wilkinson
if a resident can't get hold of rochford
district council they will get hold of
their ward councillor
or any councillor they can happen to
find as i was contacted
this weekend on a flood potential
flooding issue
uh between myself and councillor newport
and councillor stanley we addressed the
issue
but rest assured uh council wilkinson
residents will find somebody to phone um
and if if that happens then you know we
pretty much all pull together and get
the issue
resolved to the best of the residents
solution but they will get hold of
someone rest assured thank you
councilman um council and mrs mason
uh thank you mr chairman can you confirm
you can hear me
i can hear you yes yep excellent um
obviously i can't
say you're here um i'd just like to go
back to the point that councillor
uh stanley rates and i think he's got a
fair point
um i'm sure many of the more senior
members would
will remember the last time we had
serious flooding in this area
the rdc via a previous leader advised
residents to go in the middle of floods
to be in queue to
collect sandbags
i would have hoped that this council has
moved on for that
and would consider being more proactive
for its residents sandbags might have a
limited use
but at least they give reassurance they
do have some use
and they should be there available for
our residents
now as a council we are aware of the
areas
that are likely to flood in our region
we know where the potential risks are
i don't think it would be unreasonable
to have a small store
for residents to access or even for
councillors to access
should there be a very localized
emergency
can i ask that this is referred back to
the flood forum to look at this again
we should be supporting our residents
especially when it's something
as disastrous and distressing as
flooding
so can i ask for that to go back to the
flood forum for them to
consider councillor stanley's point
thank you
thank you councilman mrs mason um
[Music]
matt is that something you could take up
chairman i'm very happy to take that
back to the flood forum and raise that
gym
thank you very much um councillor mr
shaw
sorry chairman's having trouble muting
um going back to
the sandbags um i know that um
stanbridge parish council do hold a
stock of
emergency sandbags and perhaps other
parishes
could do the same
thank you council mr shaw
um it'll be up to the flood forum to
coordinate that i think and that's a
very helpful information yeah thank you
councillor mr shaw
and councilman gooding
yeah on the subject of the flooding i
just would like to know
when the next flood forum will be please
thank you um matt is that something you
can answer or
do you have an idea of uh i can confirm
that this week we've been uh making
contact with
uh with partners to call a meeting of
the platform we don't have the data yet
but jeff and colleagues uh are
coordinating um only this week to
arrange one so
that will happen very very shortly too
thank you um i had
cancer mrs shaw first actually
yes sorry i was gonna actually ask the
same um questions counselor gooding
but going on from that and matt's answer
um
i appreciate we're looking at you're
looking about doing a meeting but we're
getting some more heavy weather coming
in
um within the next couple weeks is there
any time we can get it done quickly
sooner rather than later please
chairman will we are relying on on
partners of course to come back to us we
will push that as quickly as we can
um we are allowing our partners to come
back to us um but as jeff has said we
are
the platform is about coordinating our
you know our overall response with all
our partners to this so uh we'll
certainly push that through
i know jeff is picking up and working
with partners too we do take a
coordination role
of the group uh and we will make contact
continue to make contact um as soon as
we can
thank you very much thank you
council mrs shaw uh yeah matt if you
could do and maybe just
stress mrs shaw's point that sooner may
be better
than later um councillor stanley
thank you chairman just just one point
uh the the
the army tend to use an awful lot of
sandbags
as you noticed on the floods up up
towards the midlands
uh they used an awful lot of sandbags
and they actually held back some of the
rain
some of the water that was flooded
everywhere but these sandbags that i'm
talking about don't actually hold sand
they only inflate when there is water
present
so they are flat packs almost and won't
take up a lot of room
uh one of our councillors did have
a few of them and was able to take them
around to a resident to help them out of
the problem
um and also we was offered some sandbags
from
rtc's own store which was in the
in the grounds in their garage from
councillor spearing which
was very kind of him to offer
thank you councillor stanley um
i don't think there are any other
questions um
obviously i think mrs council mrs mason
has
asked for um her suggestion to the flood
forum which matt you've confirmed you
will do
um and obviously look to try and arrange
a flood for a meeting as soon as
possible
um the rest of the report is just for
members to know
um one one thing i would say um this is
the second time that
this has come before the review
committee when um or since i've been
a chairman and i do think whilst um the
report is
um fundamentally uh good and i
understand it and
fairly comprehensive i would like to see
in possible uh in future reports
but just a little bit more data we have
touched on it this evening um
regarding number of calls um
you know statistics with regards to how
many of those calls have been gone on to
be actioned which ones haven't um and i
would just be interested to to see a
little bit of data about how
often this service is being used um and
the results of
of that is that something you could
maybe look to do in future reports for
us
sam is absolutely fine uh we have
regular logs and
jeff has regular conversation with with
the caroline provisions here more than
happy to include some stats in terms
of numbers of calls follow-up actions
you know
um outcomes uh themes i think it would
just be useful for members
and i think it would just give members a
bit of a better idea of exactly
um how important this service is i think
we know the importance but
um how often it's being used um
i think it would just give members a
clearer picture of exactly what this
does for our residents more than have to
take that away
thank you and i've just noticed
councillor williams did you want to ask
a question
thank you chairman as a visiting member
and as
portfolio holder for the environment i
can give you some information i have
requested
from um ads and
and jeff um to to organize a
uh platform as soon as possible i'm sure
i'm confident they'll do that as quickly
as i can
we've also had issues this weekend down
at sherbrooke sorry
say should we um great wakering
regarding possible floods
and i have to say the environment agency
and angling water there
much more quickly than we were um so
the residents do know what to do the
people that are under threat do tend to
know
where to go and yeah just to to keep
your
advice of that thank you
thank you council williamson council
mcpherson
thank you chairman um i'm obviously
sorry i'm just going to comment on what
uh councillor
williams has just um relayed um
yes residents do know what to do and
they did in wakering
but when we've got somebody ringing the
environment agency every half hour
from 3 30 a.m till 6 30 a.m until she
finally got through to them
and then continuously calling them so
they knew where to go
what to do etc um and that isn't the
only resident there was quite a few
they shouldn't be doing that this is why
we've got a flood forum to bring these
agencies together
so yep the sooner the better especially
with the forecast of rain
i don't want my residents having to go
through that again thank you
thank you councillor mcpherson um
actually i'm sorry
members just one last question i i did
actually have i've just i've just seen
it
um on 6.1 um page 7.3
it just gives members a bit of
information and says that out of
out of hours emergency calls are taken
by our partners kendrink airline
and just a quick question about that is
is that um
a contract with with tendering and if so
what's what's the kind of frequency or
duration of that contract and
is it up for renewal are you generally
are you happy with it
yeah chairman it was it was part of a
procurement process so
tender and caroline won that process um
jeff can answer how long was left on the
contract it was renewed
a couple years ago i want to say jeff
but jeff for another detail yeah a
formal process for more tendering
process
with them and that they do they answer
as rochelle district council so it's
very clear
you know upon answering who they are you
know who they're operating for
um jeff you know regularly monitors that
contract he provides detail
pack so they know what information to
give and that pack is
is developed from the information that
service leads provide essentially so
they know the detail of the sort of
details to provide initially and you
just provide training with them so
they're familiar with the district
um so yes i mean we'll always it's
always rupert improvement all contracts
of course but
um but yes um it's part of jeff's
monitoring of that
of that contract jeff i think we're
about halfway through that contract are
we um
no we're actually coming towards the end
of it so we'll be going out to
contract again uh later this year
thank you okay i'll get the impression
from the report that you
you seem relatively happy with the
current um partners tendering care line
yes probably speaking yes so always room
for improvement but um
uh from the information we've got so far
and what we've done with them yes bro to
be happy
lovely thank you okay members um
the recommendation is to note the
contents of the report are members happy
to do that
if you are not if you can just indicate
either by
the you raise hand icon or or another
way but
if you are happy to know can you just
indicate you are
yeah lovely thank you very much
um okay jeff matt you're more than
welcome to stay
i don't know if you are intending to or
if you if you want to leave thank you
for
for coming this evening sharon if it's
okay with you and the
other members i'll leave the meeting now
but uh thank you for your time
thanks for coming thank you take care
okay members agenda item number eight
which is the key decisions document
hopefully everyone's
had a chance to to have a look at that
that document
and there are three items on the key
decision document
and the first one is 7 20
and i think um council mrs mason
i know we did this last time would you
like me to just read out the
subject matter for you
okay i've i've been counting this is
going to be lost
yeah just temporarily gone okay i think
just for the the sake of
um the recording i'll just read that out
quickly so
the um first key decision which is 720
disposal of former redundant crown hill
public conveniences
and this is to the subject matter is
disposal a form of redundant
crownfield public convenience is subject
to marketing and granting
permission for a future leasehold
agreement um
the decision for that is dual this is
going to go to executive in march
any members have any questions regarding
that
okay uh the second is 10
20. and this is the waste collection and
street cleansing contract
this is to agree arrangements in respect
of the waste collection and street
cleansing
contract beyond the 21 22
financial year i understand that report
is on the agenda for the executive which
is scheduled for tomorrow
any members any questions
uh council hawkington thank you chairman
um
please shoot me if i've got this the
wrong way around
we discussed may not be in the last
meeting maybe in the meeting before but
we discussed
the waste contracts and street cleansing
is this report that's going to the
executive what we discussed
or is there a further report that's
going to them that's then going to come
to us before full council have i got
that the wrong way around
um my understanding and i might have to
refer to sonia but i thought mine's
saying was that this is what we
discussed
right good that makes sense then thank
you is that correct sonia do you know or
would you be able to seek clarification
for council wilkinson
yes i i can um my understanding is that
that um that that that is what was
previously uh discussed it's all around
the uh the procurement process
for those contracts and um you know
i can provide further clarification
outside the meeting if members would uh
would like
okay um councillor sparring you may be
able to address that
thanks chairman yeah um if there is any
changes council willgins and i haven't
spotted them
um by and large it is exactly the same
i think um it's one of these situations
i think we've covered just about
every option that we can possibly do but
a lot of the
uh situations that we've put into the
executive
is not set in sat in in in cement yet
there's so many things that we're still
waiting for for government directives
about green waste
regarding funding for new for new trucks
uh going carbon neutral so the document
being presented to executive
is as as we said discussed but it isn't
set in stone there there are still lots
of negotiation
or areas in in the document thank you
chairman
thank you councillor spain that's it
that's really helpful is that okay
council of wilkinson
yes thanks very much makes perfect sense
thank you thank you
um okay fire the third key decision
um which is under me is 11 forward slash
20
that's the voluntary sector grant
allocations for 2021-22
and that's to agree funding allocations
from the voluntary sector grants
pot i understand the report is due to go
to the executive in march
and that will be followed by a portfolio
holder decision on funding allocations
um council hookway
thank you chairman um you know obviously
um
in light of the current situation um
i know in the past that uh there was uh
member involvement in relation to uh
the allocation of uh the uh
this particular part of money um
is his member involvement will be
part of the process uh this year
um with regard to how that how the funds
are allocated out to
all the various different applicants
um thank you council that's not
something unfortunate i don't think i'm
going to be able to
answer this evening um
sonia is that something that we could
take away from this meeting and ask
do we yes yes i think um i think um at
this stage the best thing i can suggest
is if i um if i if i go away and talk to
the assistant director louisa moss and
an update members outside the meeting
thank you sonia is that okay council
hook one
uh yes yes fine thank you chairman
thank you very much the other question
has been on the key decisions
document um mr chairman i'm afraid i've
got the same problem
as at the last meeting in that i haven't
had this document
at the last meeting afterwards i spoke
to two officers neither
knew who how to obtain the
um document on the council's website
um i asked them to advise me and i must
admit i've overlooked it i've been busy
no one's advised me no one's come back
to me on that
and i haven't managed to see it and as
you'll be aware
the connection dropped out so i've only
just managed to get back into the
meeting
so could you just very roughly run
through the key decisions document
because
i've no idea what's on it
and i would ask again for the officers
to advise me how to ask
chairman yes councillor mcpherson
point of order um is this really
necessary
we've just literally been through this
document again it's no fault of any
member here
that um any phone line
uh failed um and also the key uh
decisions document
i did explain the last meeting right
hand side
menu full fight and down key decisions
document
they're always stored under they always
have been well i've asked the officers
they couldn't find it and they couldn't
advise me two senior officers
so um and i'm afraid your directions
don't help me when i'm looking at
something totally different
at the moment you'll appreciate that the
council's equipment's failed
i'm having to come in on the phone for
some reason the phone
disconnected i've missed part of the
meeting because of technical issues i'm
just merely asking for a very brief
summary
of part of the meeting that i've
inadvertently missed council mcpherson i
mean if that causes you offense
i'm sorry but i would just ask the
chairman just to give me the titles
so i know if there's anything that i
should be aware of
it's perfectly cursive
thank you i don't think it was causing
council mcpherson any offense i think
she was
just trying to be helpful um well
she'd like to be helpful after the
meeting as i said last time after the
meeting
then and to assist me as the officers
haven't been able to
then i would appreciate that but i don't
think the time for
technical advice and for technical
instructions
in a meeting is very helpful thank you
thank you
councillor knowing knowing councilman
chris and i don't think she'll have a
problem doing that at all for you
no it's fine thank you that's wonderful
thank you
so just very quickly i am just going to
run through the titles of these
councilmembers
make sure that the decision was
regarding the disposal of former
redundant crown hill public conveniences
the second key decision is regarding
waste collection and street cleansing
contracts
and the third key decision was the
voluntary sector grant allocations for
2021-22
presuming that's being done with um
group leaders i don't know
how it's being done well at the moment
uh councillor hookway has raised a
question
and we feel that the um best option at
the moment is for
sonia to go back to the assistant
director who is louisa moss
to ask her um or to answer that question
so i think sonia if we could just also
um include there um just ask louisa moss
whether or not that group involves group
leaders
okay thank you and thank you
um agenda item number nine which is the
work plan
again members um i hope people had a
chance to look at this we've
come into the end of this um this
municipal year so we've only got two
meetings left the second of march
where we will be looking at community
safety partnership
an update on animal welfare welfare
sorry licensing and
april's meeting which is the 13th of
april which will be the approval of the
review committee's annual report
um
can i indicate mrs mason yeah
yeah no okay thank you just
two points um on the the work plan
um last year the approval of the review
committee's annual report
um we didn't have an opportunity to
approve it
so can it be circulated quite early to
ensure that
members don't have any questions they
can do so i
i know it was a difficult situation last
year yeah
that was um yeah just to answer that i'm
not
criticizing i'm just asking yeah just
make sure that we do get it in time
um because last time it wasn't completed
at the mem
at the meeting and it was um sent
through to full council without being
circulated to members which
yeah it's still on the agenda mrs
um mason it is still on the work plan
under additional items so it is still
there so
it can be carried over and will be
reviewed
as soon as we're able to i am liaising
with officers they know that this is
something i've mentioned
um and we have discussed it
okay thank you mr chairman and the other
thing just
just um for information for the
committee you'll be aware there's a
working group for the open space
management
unfortunately officers have not been
able to provide the reports that were
commissioned last
january i mean a year ago last january
we're still waiting for those
i'm expecting to get them or i'm hoping
to get them within that we have had some
information but not the information
we're requesting
once that information is available a
meeting date will be sent
set as soon as possible but there's no
point in us holding
a working group without the documents
that we've requested
so that's just to update you on that
thank you
thank you council mrs mason um
any members any questions regards to the
work plan
doesn't appear to be the case um and
that then brings the meeting to an end
at 8
45. um thank you everybody for attending
this evening
um take care i hope you'll stay safe and
i'll see you
all soon thank you thank you